the organizers for this event I have to
face that fact that it's easier to have
invested because the 15 ml sorry pounds
desk ear in US or abroad than me romance
with sleepy pants till now opened in
Francis black history it's very
interesting
and but it's funny because this year I
don't like you know but this year is a
flawless adventure declared by you know
and in France other states and france
are the negation to apply this
reservation for two by the Human Rights
Council and they don't Indians you don't
don't do anything for the aphorism
people of course but the effect right
they read the hood Hamer Carolyn
Martinique Guadeloupe and they are all
the Dominion the Caronia Dominion it's
very funny and also we have to post up
to the feather is more for
incorrect
that's the reason I am about to travel a
lot in at this time the cannot stay
friends okay as everywhere the question
of the equity of family stone on the
tables back on is on the table and I
will not see this actually based on the
context of white pony crisis economical
and also I was concerned that why she's
opinion
what we call a revolt Arab and not
spring gala and not revolution are given
result our basic bit of a new admission
50 years after father's death we are to
note that despite the changing world he
reminds a burning figure of surprising
relevance even through coronary disease
in his old forms as disappeared and many
states free from foreign elevation of
energy sixty years after the Second
World War 53 years after the band room
conference in which people previously
ignored and deprived of any right under
the main area of the right of people to
say that ammunition express rebellion
against the static cone imposed by the
colonial domination of European State
and begins the imposition of
in which they were alpha stage can we
say that the disposition animation and
interesting a blessed soul what was
balancing in 50 years ago as elaborate
is sinking underwater violence in the
liberation process and the risk facing
the former paralyzed once independence
achieved after alpha century the result
of independence is Erica irrevocable oh
but people are not invigorating from an
inauguration that man units and unit
seven freedom Fred form misery
industries and neglect that the sufferer
builder Colin your own societies are
still orphans of states that are not yet
being born and that exists within
neo-colonial
networks that import how we are able to
change according to their interest
successor of power by the national
boards which finds found Rolly
identified in the nasal to the prophecy
national in Danny leather I'm sorry I
quote in french because i cannot i don't
have any english translation in my
other hand present in a tragic misuse of
auntie corrie Australia he described
years before it becomes obvious the
neo-colonial pathology as the
perpetration on her management by
corrupted and owned teetotaler
government that obeys an interest of
former colonial power plant once wrote
the book latinas gonadal horrid before /
a fun diversion for the nod it will go
to assist in developing some new soft
economy class canoes a autograph on hulu
in nursery director who presume it
already been allocated Alfonso 60 also
narcissist monopolies that both ways in
national service in mobile banking can
be facing more complicated oversee my
favorite denim melody cobleskill a
negative ad no kidding me but a closer
shave the hairs from catastrophic inner
vision and also the suspect Oh
on direction velocity emetophobia maybe
two top here can any see there is
activity at the media advil owners
three-dollar convene that from it was a
bogus one fulfilled the prophecy
nasrullah a toxicology don't affair not
the cap attendance to encode the elite
use of their former colonizers making
this the triumph of business culture
which seems to be only the caricature of
Western mundo as a result liberation
movement adopt the fall of the unique
party called for Nevada indelicate a few
books worth some masks so far Sanskrit
reading and God in addition to the are
the socio-economic level the exits of
all authoritarian governments that have
been a companion
by a disastrous management of only earth
to protect the interest of former
Coronation which are today more present
than emeril at the strategic level the
difference agreement are following the
installation of bases and their prophecy
and airport facilities in natural
airports and reporter system are under
foreign place to division which means
much about the state of subordination it
is clear that in the absence of tory
national test fitting the way was it
went to provide the leadership this
prevented the formation of state in the
service of their people final was afraid
that if the new workers continue to be
worn by the master of yesterday then the
mood even Terry called the
disintegration of these new states for
in building a just and prosperous
society has to go through the total
liberation of men and women from the
legacy of paralysis which makes it
essential to edit and identify after
effects and eliminates the devastating
effect
presence this has not operated the
process of independent as Kim not being
achieved but the Transfiguration of
colonization does not stop there we must
are the coronial dimension of
humanitarian intervention with to which
Jupiter to open war in Libya and
otherwise permanent installation of NGOs
supplying boots too weak and fragile
state and maintaining the population
especially in rural rural the rails in
evolution of structural assistantship so
renew domination is done in good
conscience but it is the paternal and
generalized neo-colonial war against
terrorism which is divine the arrival of
military extra continent our forces for
answering the protections of the
interest of multinational company and
the region's most effective Isis trend
our source where there is potential and
strategic resources interim not operated
yet one must have to this the new start
stage of in Paris
contemporary globalization which
consists of opening the market of the
least developing country to
multinational but the strategy of 14
along azera for the African and Arab
countries in world market as a source of
supply of raw materials our word it is
challenged by the immigrants of
directors the emerging economies
challenge neo-colonial forcing fast fest
and we could see them the order of a
stand battle regime start to falter and
those applause of popular uprising as in
Tunisia and Egypt this fact forces
within the practical framework of
international relations the Western
powers to accommodate their relationship
with white DC access from round in your
house after the eternal
against terrorism that has earned the
support of the multilateral sheep the
basic of these collections has been
enriched with and wardens omniauth of
the protection of civilian were looked
under a legal responsibility to protect
which war as can be seen right now in
Syria according to the window wall of
the worst entails it's not over after
the battle has fixed all of the bottom
dependencies succeeding with the rise of
lyric on silicon disk in the West a
so-called public event which appeared
recently as a speech of right-wing
convicted not hesitating to publicly
express tennis with clear resist veggies
the colonial violence was for went by
and indirect violence where the corner
older contaminated the territory from
the
so neo-colonial parents with an
organization under a new phone including
two African continent and are rather
slim up but what it is new is that now
even the Box Turtle Rock is affected all
the people are subjected to a
neo-colonial international order based
on violence creatine and economic and
social order based on generals misery in
the name of and built exclusively for
the benefit of prevent interest in
addition an empire an impartial observer
might say in light of bloody impire
works in Iraq Afghanistan and Libya but
also of colonial relation in Palestine
so gunboat diplomacy on which the
colonial empires have been built was
back in active service
to sing to sing from fans a condition of
the form of countries under colonial
rule is an exact science of
confrontation confrontation where the
reality is clear of energy blenders and
free from any develop in his respect
contrary to those two want oh who would
like see phenom ii gonna feed or from it
and fan on at the same time and
psychiatrists and our giant OJT the
pan-african revolutionary an ambassador
and a fighter for the emancipation of
all is more relevant than ever women go
through last sentences of black skin
white masks port more blonde du coup de
Genova colossians o virgin eldest women
domine room process ahren elessedil
small lump a homo sapien dome open kima
swap a minute
you are alone who is at home and both
subjected to fans ki baratan criticism
the system of bowlers reveal themselves
for what the art system of oppression
and offer under under root of all prayer
team economic social and cultural
blockage independence was emptied of its
democratic condensed and expose its very
own immunity so freedom for which the
poor are ways in protest was confiscated
by author it is supported by the formula
for an answer domination are only
challenging apparence virtual
empowerment is yet to come for phenom
hoyt lon e bahara on TV janashree party
barisan nasional in the Coptic it as
relational in exists to Donna news view
of coolant video are enough see
universal remote areas and cold
unfortunately with a few exception the
society freed from colonial rule our
society's wizard citizens the goal at
the down of the second phase of
independence easter is to be very very
is to clean again a political content to
the oppressor in which he named the
people will be fully recognized and
without which provide evidence is only a
caricature the liberation of human being
is a universal struggle and the
political meaning of the struggle is
based on the defense of public and
private residence the root of general
interest the reduction of in equal
is the accountability of elected people
and the sovereignty of flu financed
stubbornness and determination show that
there is no inability of failure nor the
drama can just be the neutral mode of
life of the people the solidarity's of
progress and conversions of struggles
resistance to dictatorship and to
neo-colonial and in biology money's all
the milestones on the road to recovery
solidarity
international Isis and that of fennel is
on an unchanging example give a more
human dimension to the struggle of the
panel and light Alex I kept it's a
sickness and activist the colonized
world United yet highly differentiated
and wis contradiction so for final there
are little differences in the struggle
of the dominated people whether in the
garden Africa of 40 South America the
political and social dislocation
characteristic of exploitation and
expression Adam to Leah to unify the
subject eight ball for the interest of
the small minority the treatment in spas
and buries face prefer ended made with
help of Ultron in the world european
union and lance is a revelation of
strategy to dinner sorry social advance
implemented
in the richest countries colonial Google
goog on top Ruben master et is now as
the head of around itself to society of
security built in the name of fighting
terrorism contribute to the
criminalization of it exclude and a
spoon the media coverage of resin Fiat
in England is reminiscence of that
deployed in France during the 2005
rewards by successive shift fascinated
by the superposition of social and
cultural tested the poor black hair
artistry the Western system reject
colonial speech in their domestic
political refuge and both xenophobic law
by paradox which history as a secret the
nitrogen become ubiquitous not only in
his material range but also in what
final quarter forbidden city where the
way you form of discrimination are
announced from inadequate that called
the Monford on isn't it among to build
has already tape on equal and easy pop
open available soon apt Vallecano Sidhu
soon suppose we notice at least this
Simone Favaro be under heavy paper
dispenser on the negative effects to
kyrenia secure a very physically mcafee
is immediately in love with her most
emotive the park and Jeanette Alaskan
amenities name and hope for soles4souls
move on and colonial past present
injustice and disposition finance work
would be conceived as honest apology of
violence these critiques are reported
amor mio conservative intellectuals that
after two poor go through the witch and
there is wedding and profit organization
reflects a lack of knowledge of cannons
war and the rest is bad faith the
violence advocated by panel are the
intimate means of self and wait on west
lies those who have been named exploit
and then save it is that or
fans of the oppressed Lucifer and even
an even greater violence of diminution
disposition and contact but the are
minor position and Papa donne-moi a
reality is sternberg the Mackenzies so
we can exist is a google relation
between former colonies and former
colonial for a steal at war the water
turn of citizenship submission and
passcode and the spirit of resistance